it's the medicine millions around the
world are desperate to receive
but many across europe have already
decided to shun it
vaccine skepticism runs high in many
nations and in few places more than
france
where recent surveys suggest around half
the population
are reluctant to receive a jab against
kovid
this is one of the most active so-called
anti-vaxx platforms in france
run by a woman who believes her daughter
and others developed autism
from childhood vaccines a claim widely
disputed by the medical profession
she fiercely defends her right not to
have a covered
inoculation
villain
france is yet to vaccinate more than the
most vulnerable against kovid and there
are big questions about how many people
will come forward
in a nation where vaccine hesitancy long
predates the current virus
health expert dr caroline depose says
past scandals including a since disputed
link
between the hepatitis b vaccine and
multiple sclerosis in the 1990s
have lodged in the french psyche la
francaise
[Music]
confidence in france hasn't been helped
by worries about side effects with the
astrazeneca
covid vaccine and the initial decision
to withhold it from the elderly
even some health professionals have been
reluctant to take it
i'm against it especially when we see so
much pushback and that even nursing
staff don't want to be vaccinated
it's kind of in our culture the french
always very reluctant to take drugs
vaccines all that and i find it a shame
that people are refusing
it's their choice everyone is free to do
whatever they want
but i think it's unreasonable if
everyone does as they see fit
and no one vaccinates we won't move
forward
but now france's medicine academy has
called for covered vaccines to be made
obligatory for nurses and other health
professionals
a bigger challenge may be bringing
pressure to bear
on millions of citizens michelle
clifford sky news
leo